-♪♪ 1, 2, 3,
Think Fast! ♪♪
All right.
Here's how it works.
-Okay.
-Even the song is fast.
[ Light laughter ]
Here's how it works.
We're gonna take turns
drawing one of these cards.
Each card has five totally
random questions on it, okay?
One person asks the questions,
The other person has to answer
each question
as soon as it's asked,
and I mean immediately.
It doesn't matter if the answer
is right or wrong.
It just has to be the very first
thing that pops in your head.
Dakota,
because you're the guest,
I'll read your questions first.
-Okay.
Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
-Are you getting nervous?
-Yeah.
-No!
There's no right or wrong.
You already won.
-Okay.
I already won.
-All right, ready?
-All right, bye.
-No, no, no!
We have to play the game.
Hey, ready?
-Okay, yeah.
-Here we go.
-Okay, go.
-Yep. I know.
I just want to do
the mood lighting first.
-Oh, wow.
-What do you want
for your birthday?
-Everything.
-Where does Mrs. Mumphrey live?
-In my house.
-What's the worst thing
you can put in coffee?
-Poo.
-Bap, bap --
how many times did I say bap?
[ Laughter ]
Why is Richard the best?
-Just 'cause.
-There you go.
That's how easy it is.
Just like that.
It's that --
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Both laugh ]
"Just -- Just 'cause.
Just 'cause Richard's the best."
All right.
And you couldn't even say --
you couldn't even say two.
You had to do it
with your fingers.
[ Both laugh ]
All right, now it's your turn.
You ask me the question.
-Okay.
-All right, here we go.
Wait for the lighting effect.
-Okay.
♪♪♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Ready?
-Yeah.
-Who was that boy?
-He was --
I never met him.
[ Laughter ]
-What is your band's name?
-Gulag.
[ Laughter ]
-Why should I believe you?
-I'm tall.
-What's another word for socks?
-Booties.
[ Laughter ]
-How do you flirt?
-Like this.
[ Laughter ]
[ Bell dinging ]
Flirt with anyone?
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's the pressure!
-I know.
-It's a lot of pressure
even though
they're just silly questions.
All right,
here's the way this works.
This is the final round.
In this round,
we'll both pick up a card
with the same
set of questions, okay?
We're gonna ask and then answer
them one at a time,
going back and forth.
You will go first.
Are you ready?
-What?
No, you -- you go first.
-Okay.
-Well, mine starts
at number two.
-Oh, it does?
Okay, yeah, all right.
[ Laughter ]
I didn't look at the card yet.
Thank you for coming
to rehearsals, by the way.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
[ Both laugh ]
Who invented peanut butter?
-I did!
[ Laughter ]
How do you say
"octopus" in Russian?
-Octoposa.
[ Laughter ]
What is a shonsky?
-It's a thing
that you find on the floor.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, God.
-What does your
outgoing voicemail say?
-H-i-i-i-i!
[ Laughter ]
Leave a message.
B-y-y-ye!
Who do I look like?
-Uh, my mom?
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-[ Laughing ]
That's the best thing
anyone's ever said to me.
-Oh, my God.
I'm really crying now.
-Okay.
-This is the worst cry
I've ever had on this show.
Okay.
-Six.
[ Laughter ]
All right, ready?
-Was that a question?
-No, I'm sorry.
No, no, you're number six.
Yeah, go, yeah.
-What is the slogan for cows?
-Moo! Moo!
[ Laughter ]
What do you bring
to the Super Bowl party?
-Oh, uh, my purse.
[ Laughter ]
How do you get good?
-By practicing.
[ Laughter ]
Why is Thomas crying?
-Because you
really hurt his feelings.
[ Laughter ]
-There you have it.
That was "Think Fast!"
with Dakota Johnson!
[ Cheers and applause ]